welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled how to improve her2
testing accuracy
incorporating the 2018 asco cap focused
update
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
hattie yazzagi
the medical director of vitro molecular
laboratories in miami florida
dr yaziji's area of expertise is breast
pathology and breast cancer biomarkers
especially her2 protein and gene testing
dr yaziji has received several
prestigious achievement awards including
alpha omega alpha honor medical society
and the southern medical association
pathology section
achievement award he is also co-authored
over 55 publications
in peer-reviewed journals for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box
our speaker will address your questions
following the presentation
please join me in welcoming dr hadi
yasiji
i will now turn the presentation over to
him dr yaziji
thank you very much jennifer for the
nice introduction i appreciate it i
appreciate the invitation
um so we
i have a couple disclosures uh
to make which are on the slide and i
would like to dedicate the talk to all
of the breast cancer survivors
including her two positive patients
so just a quick word about myself with
her too i believe
we published one of the first if not the
first quality assurance programs on her2
testing with fish you know when i was a
resident in pathology
prior to it actually toward the end of
my residency and beginning of my
first fellowship that's when
therapeutic applications of anti-her2
targeted therapy
became available and approved
by the regulatory agencies and
[Music]
but nobody taught us how to perform the
test how to interpret the test
so i have to confess i'm actually a
self-taught
fish pathologist nobody taught me how to
read fish slides
and the first time i was introduced to
the term
to the acronym fish which is
fluorescence inside the hybridization
um is when i believe uh
there was a talk at the city at the
kosair children's hospital by a renowned
uh sector geneticist
actually dr hirsch and he was talking
about the use of
this new test new technology called fish
to detect fragile x syndrome you know
and that was just a
basically a grand round presentation in
1993
i believe and nothing else happened
after that until 99 when fish was
approved as one of the testing
modalities
in for her2 and
i was asked as a junior pathologist by
my senior
pathologist all right you're going to
start our fish program
great wonderful exciting but how do we
do it
so actually i designed the quality
insurance program to correlate between
ihc and fish
and we published our findings in 2004
i was fortunate enough to participate in
the asco cap
task force discussions i was not my name
is not included in the articles because
i was
representing one of the commercial
laboratories so we are not supposed to
be co-authors
but we participated in the setting the
guidelines on the discussions
uh our laboratory adjudicates the
her discrepancy status between oncotype
results and
[Music]
the originating her two results whether
the testing was done by imminent
chemistry or fish
and we actually validated some of the
commercially available her2 assays
and that would be actually another
disclosure
um developed an assay to use
immunofluorescence and fish
in special settings where it is
necessary
to localize the target area better
uh because the with the fish it is
difficult to
recognize the topography where the tumor
is the invasive tumor where the dcis is
if there is dcis
and where the benign areas are
so this is the agenda we're going to
have a quick introduction
and jump straight through into some
common misconceptions
after that we will discuss the focused
updates
and then we'll spend a few minutes
talking about these
gray zone tumors what i would like to
refer to them as grazon tumors
and then we'll mention uh the some
special scenarios
um you know i have personally looked at
over 23
000 fish slides related to her2 in
breast cancer
so i have i can say that i i have seen
it all actually
so we'll we'll go over some of these
special scenarios and then
spend the last few minutes to discuss
how to improve
her2 testing accuracy and these are
helpful hints that i apply
myself so everything i say here
everything i advocate
i actually do so what i do what i say i
do
it's there and then we'll open it to uh
questions
and we'll be mindful of the time
hopefully there will be sufficient
amount of time for questions afterward
so this is a kind of a probe diagram so
the
her2 fish assay includes two probes the
one that targets the actual
gene which is the locus specific probe
uh the gene is located on the
long arm of chromosome 17 and it's
actually close enough to the centromere
which poses some issues actually which
we'll we'll uh
briefly touch on later and the control
probe is the centromere
uh pro
the green color
okay so to the right of of that
chromosome map there is an illustration
of a negative result which is basically
what you see
in about 80 of breast cancers
and then uh underneath that a positive
result
where which we which we you would see in
the remaining
uh percentage uh now
um the
mechanism of her2 protein expression is
gene amplification now that covers
the vast majority of scenarios
now it doesn't cover 100 of them
there are exceptions but these
exceptions in my opinion
are exceedingly rare so
her2 protein expression is a direct
result
of her2 gene amplification
again with rare exceptions and we do see
these rare exceptions every once in a
while
now given the fact that the drug targets
the protein
and doesn't target the gene uh
the protein status becomes more
informative for treatment decisions than
gene status
and that's an important point from a
therapeutic standpoint
so if there are oncologists listening to
this talk
anytime there is a discrepancy which is
in my opinion
exceedingly rare between the protein
status and the gene status
anytime there is a discrepancy we rely
more on the protein status than the gene
status for treatment purposes
okay because again the drug doesn't
target the gene it targets the protein
so that's important to remember but the
good news
is the those scenarios where there is
discrepancy are
few and far between
so this illustrates a her2-negative
tumor on the
left side with a negative immunistic
chemistry and negative
fish associated with it and
her2-positive tumor on the right side
with a positive
or two protein expression which is
basically a membranous
chicken wire pattern and a positive fish
assay which shows an increased number of
those
red colored gene labeled
probes i'm sorry fluorescently labeled
so just a very quick word about the
targeted therapy
biology there are we're not going to get
into the pathways the cancer pathways
associated with her2 gene expression but
just a quick word about the
how the increase
copy number of the gene leads to an
increase of protein copy number and how
that
affects the biology of her2 positive
breast cancers
we actually don't know the exact answer
but it seems like
the dimerization just by the fact that
the her2 receptors become extremely
numerous
then the process of dimerization of two
her2 receptors next to one another
or that's called homodymerization or
heterodymerization between her2 receptor
and another epidermal growth factor
receptor family protein
whether it's her one her four or her
three that dimerization
triggers these pathways uh basically
activates these pathways and
enables them to send signals
downstream that will really affect the
potential aggressiveness of the cancer
cell and the cancer itself
okay so
let's jump straight into some
misconceptions
and that's really uh basically a summary
of the phone calls
i get from my colleagues who are either
oncologists or pathologists
asking me hey you probably messed up my
the results of my patients
didn't you pay attention to the tumor
grade and whatnot
so we'll go over these um one by one
so the um first of all
uh one of these misconceptions is
low-grade tumors are always
her2-negative that's actually
right and not right you know so that is
correct
uh in the majority of the cases but not
always correct
and then the special type tumors like
globular mucinous and tubular tumors
are always too negative again that is
largely correct
but uh has some exceptions which we will
go over
and tumor with incomplete membranous
signal are her2
negative that is not necessarily
true and then the last one is most her2
positive tumors are high grade that also
is not necessarily true
we will go over some examples to
illustrate the point of each one of
these items
so this is a a tumor on low
magnification it looks like well that's
a nottingham grade one
tumor which is true that is a grade one
tumor
and it should not be her2 positive as a
result of that well
lo and behold this is the her2 status of
this tumor
by ifc and by fish and
her2 is definitively unequivocally
positive on this tumor that has a
nottingham grade one
or five phenotype but if we look at the
tumor nuclei up close we we notice that
actually they're not
necessarily they don't have a nuclear
score of one they have a nuclear score
of
two and uh vocally
three even so that is the point i wanna
illustrate
tumors with a nuclear score of higher
than one
all bets are off so you can actually
have a nottingham grade one tumor
that is her2 positive and i just showed
you one example of that
now that is admittedly that is not
common but it happens and we should be
aware of that phenomenon that
basically what i tell pathologists is
all of you
are molecular pathologists whether you
like it or not because you look at the h
and e and when you look at the h and e
slide you're looking at the nuclei and
the nuclei i have the blueprint
of the cell and the blueprint includes
the dna and the
the dna is really important so in my
opinion the nottingham score
uh should incorporate the if you look at
the nuclear score the nottingham grade
has the nuclear
tubular and pleomorphism i'm sorry
nuclear promoting tubular score and
mitotic index
if you take the nuclear score in
isolation
any tumor that has a nuclear score of
one which is
extremely low grade almost like benign
these tumors are never ever
or two positive and i use the word never
actually i've never seen one that's sort
of positive with a nuclear score of one
but once the nuclear score is two and
higher actually you can have
potentially you can have uh her2
protein expression as a result of gene
amplification
those tumors with protein expression
secondary to gene amplification
if you look at the copy number of the
genes it actually is low
but it's positive when it is positive
so this is an example of one of these
scenarios where a grade one tumor is
actually her2 positive
and that's one of the most common phone
calls i get like oh you messed up the
score of my tumor no i didn't
it just happened that the nuclear score
is more than
one and and if we have that
it's okay for any breast cancer to be
her2 positive
majority of them are not but there are
exceptions i showed you one of them now
this tumor is you know any pathologist
would look at this would say okay this
looks like a lobular tumor which is
correct that's an invasive lobular
carcinoma
and guess what it is positive for her to
protein expression that's a three plus
signal that i don't think anybody would
argue against
and but we look at the tumor cells up
close again these tumor cells
are higher score they have a higher
nuclear score than
your classical lobular cancers and they
have a higher nuclear score therefore
they can be positive majority of lobular
cancers are not positive
but the tumors with a higher nuclear
score especially the pleomorphic
globulars
can be can be occasionally positive over
two standard
and this is the fish result again on
this tumor
we do see definitive amplification but
the number of gene copies is not
exceedingly high it's still in the
single digits like 7 to 9 but it's not
higher than 10 and that's typical of
these tumors when they are positive in
my
experience this is an example of a tumor
that
anybody would call mucinous carcinoma
and that's fine
uh but this tumor is also positive
you know for her2 protein expression uh
again we look at the nuclei up close the
nuclear score the nuclear score
is not necessarily one it's actually two
so any of these and fish is positive in
this again it's
generally largely a single digit copy
number
but it looks like actually double digit
but in the lower double digit
in this case like maybe 12 copies on
average so these tumors
can be positive generally speaking
they're negative but i would like to
alert the pathologists in the audience
that when you have a museum's tumor with
the nuclear
score of higher than one i actually
personally do not call it business
i would say invasive drug maybe you can
say museum of features
you know but i will alert the oncologist
that the nuclear score is higher than
one and should not be called mucinous
because biologically
it's not going behave to behave like
your typical
musous store so
let's now spend a few minutes on the
focus
2018 update which i actually
participated in
and was a lively discussion with a
number of very
experienced colleagues
so we have
a scenario here where the ratio is over
two
[Music]
but the average her two copy number is
less than four and i have a cartoon
of a tumor cell with three copies three
or two copies but one chromosome 17 copy
so if you divide three over one you get
a ratio of three that's higher than two
but the average or two copy number is
less than four
now if you recall um according to the
2013 guidelines
this tumor with this kind of a ratio
score
would be actually called positive and
that was one of the most contentious
topics
uh discussed in the during the 2013
guideline deliberation
because the pathologists in the room
really didn't want to call these tumors
positive but the oncologist wanted to
give the patient the benefit of the
child
and see if we treat these patients what
the outcome would be
after data would accumulate which
is fine with me so the 2018 guidelines
actually reverse these tumors
and would default to the her2 protein
status in these tumors to determine
fish status this is the other category
where the ratio score is less than two
but the her2 copy number is more than
six so that is
group three the previous one
this one is group two this is group
three
okay these used to be called positive
flat out but
now we have to defer to her2 protein
status
and then the largest category
among these is basically group four
tumors
uh which has a ratio of uh
still less than two but an average or
two copy number between four instances
okay so we'll go over these one by one
obviously immunist chemistry there was
no change
to no significant change to the
designation of her2
protein expression and then
just a very quick word about fish single
probe my understanding is vast majority
of
laboratories when i get the cap survey
i look at the numbers of labs that do
her two single
probe tests and these labs
are rare actually that do a single
protest
so this is a diagram for these single
protests it's actually more simple
because you don't have a ratio score
um but the more complicated ones
are the tumors with
you know when you do the testing with a
dual probe because you have to do a
ratio score but you still have to pay
attention to the
single or two average copy number
so these tumors are grouped in uh five
different groups as a result we talked
about group two three and four in the
middle
uh group one is your straightforward
group
with uh positive results which is
basically fifteen to twenty four
20 percent of breast cancers and that is
the
group of tumors with a ratio more than
two and an average copy number of more
than four
or equal to equal to or greater than
four
and then on the far right side of the
slide we have group
five with a basically straightforward
negative result
with an average copy number of less than
four and a ratio score of less than two
that is the most common setting and in
between we have group two three and four
and we're gonna spend more time on these
um with the dual color i'm not gonna
spend a lot of time on this diagram
which you have in your handout but
basically group two is we talked about a
ratio of uh of higher than two but an
average copy number of less than four
and these tumors uh when we do ihc so
ihc
immunostatic chemistry is the
adjudicator of her2fish status and
that's a new thing that was
implemented and introduced as a result
of the 2018 focused update
which basically says if you have a tumor
that
is a group two okay
you're gonna actually do immunistic
chemistry regardless if you did it
before you did fish or you
or you're going to do it after you do
first now my
my suggestion to you is to always do a
minister chemistry because you may end
up with some
even though you do fish on everything
but always do ministry chemistry
because you may end up with a scenario
where the
gene status is negative but the protein
status is positive
so this is one of those scenarios where
the protein status will determine the
gene status so
basically to simplify things
you don't have to look at the diagram
just you can listen to me
if the protein status is shows a one
plus or two plus signal
then we would call the fish uh study
negative
if the protein status is three plus then
we would call the fish study positive
which is i think is a good approach and
i would agree with
now group three tumors uh is the one
that has
a higher copy number equal to
or greater than six and these tumors
but the ratio is
less than two and these tumors have that
because of an
increased copy number of the control
probe which is chromosome 17 centromere
probe
now these used to be called positive
straight out but now
we subject them to the exact same
algorithm we subject group
two so if her2ihc status
is the oneplus or zero negative
we call these tumors negative if it's
three plus positive we call them
positive
the only difference between this and
group two and subsequent group four
which we will see in a minute
is when ihc shows an equivocal signal
actually we do call this tumor
positive now in my personal experience
when i get a tumor like this with a copy
number of six and higher and a ratio of
less than two um generally speaking
ihc status is actually positive so i
don't have to worry about ic being
negative
but if ihc shows an equivocal two plus
signal we would call these tumors
actually possible now the next tumor
which is the group four which is really
the
most common scenario in these gray zone
tumors group two three and four
with group four it is exactly the same
algorithm of group
two so if you have an ihc
signal intensity of either zero one
or two plus we would call the tumor
negative by fish if ihc status is three
plus positive we call the tumor positive
by which so that's identical
to group two but group three is
different
now if we put all these together in a
single slide
basically on the left you have ihc
scores
and on the right you have fish scores
and the combination of these two
would dictate her two fish status
so again to recap tumors with the zero
or one plus
signal by ihc would be called negative
across the board by fish regardless of
the group designation
uh tumors that are i that show ih3 plus
by uh signal which is positive
they would be called positive by fish
regardless of the group designation
the only difference where fish
group designation makes a difference is
when we have an equivocal
iht 2 plus score but the
tumor shows group 3 status by fish
which is basically an average of six and
higher two copy numbers but
but the ratio score of less than two
these tumors if ihc shows two plus they
would actually be called
uh positive okay
so that is the only difference so that's
a nice slide that i put together
to illustrate to summarize the entire uh
situation with these grease on grayson
turmeric
now my prediction which actually is
correct i i made this slide
um right at the beginning in in june of
uh
2019 uh to sh to predict that actually
we will
we will end up as a result of the
focused update
we will end up with a higher number
of her2 negative tumors
as a result which is true and that
percentage
is is at least higher by five percent
now to recap the guidelines
um there was actually heavy reliance
on the if you look at bullet number four
there was heavy reliance on the nsavp
b47 trial um which
i have a little bit of a problem with
because they lumped patients with one
plus and two plus
scores together and they were not really
stratified
and the patients with one plus and two
plus scores they were excluded from the
treatment trial
from the treatment group they don't
qualify so
in my opinion actually generally
speaking the focused update did a very
good job
looking at these grazon tumors in a more
granular way and
incorporated the protein status to
stratify these tumors as to which ones
should be called negative and which ones
should be called positive
so i'm fairly satisfied with the uh
guidelines
now just a quick word about grazon
tumors grazing tumors
the way i define them don't are not
exclusive
to groups two three and four in my
opinion you can actually have a positive
tumor that we call positive no problem
uh but that's also a grazon tumor for
example if you have a tumor with
four or two copies on average and two
chromosome copies we would call that
straightforward positive
it's basically group one but to me
that tumor is no different than groups
two three and four
because the copy number is low so the
point i'm trying to make is when you
have a tumor with a copy number
near the cutoff
you really want to slow down and
look at those tumors more carefully
to sort them out you know
because to me they're just like group
two three and four but they're
classified as either either group one or
group five depending on
the count
and these tumors seem to have a biology
that is a little bit more aggressive by
the way
this is an example of a tumor that shows
um a uh let's say six over four
copies um and it's inside a vessel
and i and i put a dashed line to
highlight the endothelial lining of the
capillary where these tumor cells are
inside
so that's a vascular invasion vascular
invasion is a sign of aggression
it's an aggressive tumor obviously it's
a cool prognostic sign
so that's a patient that's a tumor with
a poor prognostic sign with a gray zone
score so the gray zone scores are not
limited to
low-grade tumors actually that you see
high-grade tumors with more
gray zone results you know so we have to
be careful with those numbers
another one look at the nuclear grade
it's actually
high this is roughly speaking three over
two
this is four over three again roughly
speaking
um that's again is the high grade tumor
i mean you look at these nuclei they're
cleomorphic they're large
they're they have an irregular contour
all of the cytologic features that we
recognize
as high so what do i do
you know to manage these grazon tumors
obviously i
follow the guidelines i still follow the
guidelines
but i pay more attention to the hormone
receptors
obviously her two ihc status and also
other things like t67 e67
is very important to look at to stratify
these tumors if it's high
and happens to be er positive it would
be
luminal b tumor basically um
i look at pr pr if it's negative or low
that actually is a poor prognostic
marker
when you have pr being negative or low
regardless of er status
especially when it's accompanied by a
relatively higher p67
p67 doesn't have to be as high as 20
it could be between 10 and 20 with a
with a low
pr status then that tumor would actually
qualify as a luminal b
and biologically and clinically probably
would would behave as aluminum beat over
and then there is space for the risk
assessment assays which is the favorite
thing for medical oncologists to order
to
sort out these patients and they get
her2 status
indirectly now just a word of caution
these risk assessment
risk assessment assays that incorporate
her2 testing
results in them they're really not
approved by the fda
for determination of her two status so
it's just an informative
essay but it's not a approved to
determine
her two status with again eligibility of
treatment so that's a word of caution
so this is another way just by text to
illustrate what i just
said in the previous slide
um and
the practical approach you know which i
hope would be
incorporated in the next guidelines
which
i would like to call these tumors are
too low the gray zone tumors call them
her2 low
instead of either positive or negative
so there would be three categories first
two positive
that is kind of straightforward or too
negative that's straightforward and then
in between
we call it we're too low and that
encompasses group
three two three and four you know so her
too low obviously we don't know
how they behave probably biologically
and clinically they behave more like a
negative tumor
but we don't know yet all right so
um let's spend a few minutes on the
special scenarios i think we're
not behind the time it's been 20 minutes
since i started
so we'll talk about heterogeneity we'll
talk about we'll talk about polysomy
versus co-amplification
and then we'll show a few examples of
uncommon hybridization patterns
so this is a tumor which clearly shows
the
heterogeneity you have tumor cells with
basically no amplification and other
next to them adjacent tumor cells with
actually a
very high number of gene copies
significant amplification so that's
heterogeneity it does happen
but it's not common to be honest with
you i don't see it
commonly and that's heterogeneity by
immunostick chemistry that parallels the
heterogeneity with fish
and that's another example of
heterogeneity where you have occasional
just only occasional positive cells but
the majority of the tumor is either too
plus or negative
and now this is an important uh slide
because it shows
uh the tumor actually is barely two plus
and it's actually negative by chris but
the
there is an associated in situ component
and then cytocomponent is positive
so these tumors you know because um
if if those if if this kind of a tumor
is sent to for oncotype dx
risk assessment sometimes you may get
actually a positive or two result and
in your laboratory as a pathologist you
reported her to result as
negative or equivocal by ihc and maybe
negative
and then you get the result from uh of
oncotype dx as
positive her2 status being positive
what would have happened in a case like
this is because the microdissection
doesn't really
factor and the dcis it's not uh you know
like
scientific micro dissection where you
only dissect the invasive tumor
her2 status is really a reflection of
the dcis in this case
and that's important you know and and
the company that does the archetype dx
pays attention to this and they actually
send the slides to us
uh to adjudicate her to status when
there's a discrepancy between the
original apology
her2 result and the oncotype dx what we
do is we dissect
we map these tumors with immunes to
chemistry amphis and we show them her2
status by
on the inside to component and invasive
components so what they do is they take
the slide
we digitally scan it for them and they
actually only dissect the invasive
component
and repeat the whole asset repeat the
whole risk assessment assay to
completely exclude the incitor component
which actually is an accurate reflection
of the risk associated only with the
invasive disease you know
which is actually important
all right so let's talk about some
uncommon hybridization patterns
this is a tumor with an amplification of
chromosome 17 centromere
this does happen it's extremely rare it
was described
for the first time actually in 2006 by
my colleague and friend dr megan troxl
when she was at ohsu as she described it
for the first time
this is an example of monosomy now this
is more common
this is more common where you see a
single copy of chromosome 17
and regardless of her two protein
gene status you see a single single copy
so that
is probably a reflection of a deletion
of the other allele we don't know unless
we do
a ray cgh on these tumors but this is
more common i actually do see this
about
one out of 50 tumors so it's two percent
two percent of the tumors have this
kind of uh genotype
and this is exceedingly rare or we
actually have a her2 deletion there's a
deletion of her two
gene either a single probe deletion or
even double probe division but in this
case it's a single probe deletion
that happens but again it's exceedingly
rare but i have seen it this one is the
other way where you have
a combination of her2 gene amplification
associated with monotony
and then with immunostore chemistry what
i refer to these
to this phenotype is the equivalent of
the quote-unquote bile canalicular
phenotype which is similar to the
biochemical
pattern of polyclonal cea or cd10 or
villain that we see
in hepatocellular carcinomas we
occasionally see this pattern with her
with breast cancers with regard to her2
protein by immunistic chemistry
and that should not actually be called
negative it should be called as
equivocal or you can call it
indeterminate
if you're not comfortable calling it
equivocal you can call it
indeterminate and
these tumors a small fraction of them by
the way
are is positive for her3 gene
amplification
so my recommendation is each time you
see this kind of
what i refer to as the bile canalicular
pattern
you have to i don't think you have a
choice you
have to perform or two fish tests
to sort these out majority of them are
actually
negative admittedly but a minority of
them is positive and the minority that
is positive
shows a stronger signal
of the virtual members signal
so the point i'm trying to drive home
here is
you do not have to have a continuous
circumferential signal around the
cell if you have a
discontinuous signal like this one which
looks almost like a bicameral pattern
pay attention to it
don't call it negative call it either
two plus or indeterminate
which will trigger a fish test and then
the fish
assay will really determine her2 status
it could be positive could be negative
majority are negative but some are
positive
and again this tumor actually this very
tumor you just looked at
has a positive uh signal count with
earthquake2 is positive in this case
by gene status just very quick word
about polysomy versus co-amplification
this is the exact same tumor
with two different filters used to take
the picture on the left you have
her2 gene which shows an average of i
would say six to seven copies
and on the right you have chromosome 17
only which shows an identical
number of chromosomes centromere copies
so what happened
here is it polysomine we used to think
it's polystomy
um which illustrated by
the fact that there are just an
increased number of copies of chromosome
17
allele we actually were wrong
all along which we were proven wrong by
my very good friend dr shelly gunn and
her colleagues and also
by a group from italy the same year
in 2009 the two investigative groups
published papers showing
basically uh if you do cgh testing
um polysomnia of chromosome chromosome
17 and breast cancer at least
is basically non-existent um
and that was the you know and you see
the red
circle surrounding the chromosome 17 it
says
zero so out of the hundred tumors that
they run cgh on to validate the assay
for breast cancer
none of them showed polystomine so
what we used to refer to as polychromy
is actually not polythermi
which probably
would be a result of potential
co-amplification
of the centromere along with the gene
kind of a level amplification
i don't really have the answer but but
it should not be referred to as polysomy
anymore
now in the next few minutes we're going
to talk about
how to improve the accuracy of virtual
testing
using tools that we already have we
don't have to use
some fancy other tests like quantitative
pcr which is a very good test
or cgh which is a very good test but in
my opinion we don't have to use those
tests in the majority of
of cases so
what do we do okay
the small tumor category we'll go over
that
in the next slide a tumor with a nuclear
score of one
these are invariably negative so looking
at the morphology looking at the nuclear
score
if you feel as a pathologist then the
nuclear score is one
these tumors should not be positive and
in my opinion
a nuclear score of one is the strongest
predictor of a negative or two protein
and gene status actually
now tumor with t67 so i really like to
look at key 67 if you have less than
five percent
these tumors uh are not really supposed
to be positive for her to
but i cannot say they're never positive
but they're not supposed to be positive
so p67 is a good
really adjunct to help you determine
her2 status indirectly
and then you have the specific
histologic features
for example the metaplastic carcinomas
uh including spindle cell carcinoma
which is known also as a
fibromatosis-like
tumor we published a study uh as i was
finishing my fellowship
at md anderson with dr snage showing
that
none of these tumors are actually
positive so spinoza carcinomas when you
have a metaplastic carcinoma whether
it's spindle cell or maybe squamous
these tumors are we can say
with some confidence that they are
invariably negative for her2 protein
expression and gene amplification
and then you have these non-mammary
tumors for example the salivary gland
type tumors like the adenoid cystic
carcinomas it's not really
even though it's triple negative but
it's not your classical
triple negative that looks basal light
these tumors are triple negative
we say triple negative meaning negative
over two
almost always negative for her2 protein
expression and
gene amplification with rare exceptions
i used to say invariably negative
until i learned my lesson one time i had
an adenoid just a carcinoma that shows a
low-level
protein expression and gene
amplification so i stopped saying
they were unvariably negative almost
invariably negative
another special type is the micro
papillary invasive micro papillary
carcinoma
these tumors it's like exactly flipping
a coin
50 percent of them show positivity so
they have a higher percentage
of them of that group being positive
compared to general breast invasive
breast cancer which is 15 to 20
when it comes to invasive micropapillary
carcinomas
these tumors actually uh 50
of them are positive with a caveat the
ones that are positive
they do not show a higher
a very high her2 gene copy number so
they show
something in the single digits usually
seven eight nine
maybe ten maybe eleven maybe twelve but
not in the higher double digit
and then the actual tumors that are
positive
what is the phenotype of these tumors
we're going to go over
that in the next slide but let's first
talk about the size of the tumor
and how it impacts virtue status how it
impacts the accuracy
of virtual status obviously the size
doesn't change the status
but a tumor with a smaller size
has a more likely tendency to
have an accurate test result and why is
that
so i i created the slides to illustrate
my point so
if you have a larger tumor generally
speaking we don't sample the entire
tumor
so there's some of it left in the
container
and when we sample it let's say we take
four slides five
i'm sorry four blocks or five blocks six
blocks okay
out of these six blocks we only test one
so if there is heterogeneity we really
don't know about
the rest of the blocks the routine
practice and i'm not advocating for
testing all of the blocks
no one block is enough but
the denominator because when we say 10
is the cutoff
between positive and negative right
when you have a small tumor the entire
tumor
more often than not is sampled in a
single block
and is represented on a single slide
the entire tumor so when we say okay we
do have some heterogeneity with maybe
two percent positive cell so we're going
to call it negative
the denominator in this case is actually
accurate because we have a full
representation of the entire tumor
when it's a small tumor but when it's a
large tumor and we have heterogeneity
and we say and the and we have some
positivity but it is less than five
percent or 10
we really don't have a clue about the
denominator 10
of what 10 percent of tumor cells in a
single block but we don't have the rest
of the blocks
and we haven't sampled the entire tumor
so the accuracy of her2 result
is maximized when you have a small tumor
it's inversely related
when you have a large tumor you may have
to test
additional blocks or maybe all the
blocks when you have heterogeneity
so that's the point to take home is
accuracy of her2 status
is in first inversely related in my
opinion to the tumor size
smaller tumors are represented on a
single cassette usually
larger tumors are not
now what do her two positive tumors look
like we all have seen them
but i would like to describe them you
see
the cytoplasm here on the low
magnification it looks a little bit
kind of pinkish i think almost like
apocrine but not
exactly like apocrine i like to
call it it's like a almost like a hybrid
between apocrine and squamous so i like
to call it
hybrid it's i like to use that term
um and this tumor is clearly positive
and up close obviously the nuclear grade
is
nuclear score it's two to three so it's
a cleomorphic
but you look at the cytoplasm there are
two things about the cytoplasm not that
it's only pink but also
if you look at the nc ratio the nuclear
to cytoplasmic ratio
the ratio is not high it actually is low
because there's a ton of cytoplasm i
don't know what it is
that enable these virtual positive
tumors to
to make a lot of cytoplasm so as a
result
the nucleus still looks ugly but the nc
ratio is actually generally speaking
it's low
not always but generally speaking it is
low that's another tumor that looks more
like a almost like a
sugar tumor you know you have a more
clear cell cytoplasm
and the with a low nc ratio look at the
nc ratio is not necessarily high it's
actually low
but you look at the nuclei they are ugly
they are
they have a score of two or even three
in some cases
that's clearly a positive tumor and then
you have the microcapillary obviously
when you have a microcapillary invasive
microcapillary carcinoma
when sorry about that when you have an
invasive microcapillary carcinoma
the 50 of these tumors are positive
okay and the signal is not continuous
that's another thing to pay attention to
you're not going to get a
circumferential signal in these tumors
and that's as good as it gets if you
want to call this two plus i'm fine with
that
but when you do fish on it actually
there is a positive signal
and notice the coffee number is not
necessarily how it's in the single
digits and that's my experience with
these tumors
so to put it all together
how do we perform the qa program at our
institution
the invasive tumor is verified on the h
and e slide obviously and
our lab is a hybrid lab we do get cases
from the local community where we
diagnose
the invasive cancer on core biopsies
usually
from imaging centers but the majority of
our her2 testing is actually referred to
us by other pathology
labs so we make an h e we look at it
obviously we make sure there is an
invasive tumor on the h e
and we always invariably even when the
client asks us to do fish only
we invariably perform ihc and i refer to
it
for tumor mapping we map the tumor make
sure if there is heterogeneity if there
are hot spots
we focus on those hot spots when we
interpret the fish results okay
so that's a tumor mapping okay and then
when i'm looking at the fish slide i
always look at the h and e and ifc at
the same time i'm looking at the first
line
okay so we have a qa program looking at
the tumor
nuclear score tumor histologic grade
ihc score and fish score one by one side
by side
and in that specific sequence the
reading is performed by a pathologist
myself or someone else
and i am purposely blinded to the
previous results i don't want to
bias myself if the if we have a
previous sample on the same patient i
would i don't want to bias myself when
i'm interpreting the news sample
but what i do is when i get to verify
the case in the final report
i look at the previous studies and i do
compare obviously and if there is
discrepancy i go back to the slides and
i dig a little bit deeper
of the new slides and the old slides to
see why there is discrepancy
and of course the metrics are mandated
by the
clia and the college of american plazas
or other regulatory agencies
so we perform the metrics i prefer
monthly metrics over quarterly metrics
in case you have a little bit of a drift
in your essay you can catch it sooner
but the good news about this program is
really
what i like to refer to as real time
real time quality control where you're
looking at the slides
side by side for every tumor in real
time
before you report the status
and that's it that's if you look at i
actually took a picture of a
folder with a few breast cancers
showing h e ihd and fish
h e ihc and fish that is our quality
insurance program
um and again we talked about how we can
predict
her2 status by looking at the h e or
even looking at the ihc obviously
and finally um
i have put together a slide
uh that explains my approach to her two
status
and so obviously on the let's focus
first on the right side of the slide
where you have
her two negative tumors that's group
five
and the her2 low tumors which i talked
about which is the gray zone which
encompasses group two
three and four and then uh
the her2 positive tumors now there are
two positive tumors are not
homogeneous they are heterogeneous how
do i split them
i look at first of all i look at her
erpr status
i look at the nuclear score i look at
the morphology
and i look at her two i'm sorry t67
status and it should make sense to
separate these two pockets
so the uh what i like to refer to as the
luminal her2 which is
basically er positive pr positive these
tumors have a nuclear score of usually
two
even when or two is positive and the
copy number is generally low in the
single digits or low
double digits and then you look at e67
the percentage of positive cells is
between 10 and 20.
now the tumors that are her2 positive
but er negative
um these tumors have the typical
what i like to refer to as swapocrine
morphology
the nuclear score is higher usually
three
and then you look at the her2 fish copy
number is actually higher it
is it is not usually single digit it's
double digit and usually it's high
double digit
and then you look at t67 status it's
actually also high
between 20 and 30 and sometimes higher
than 30 percent
that group of tumor i like to refer to
it as her2 driven so her2 actually
drives the biology and clinical behavior
of those tumors
as opposed to the other group of tumors
that happens to be her2 positive but
her2 is really not the driver
it's not the driver it just happens to
be positive these tumors
in my opinion biologically and
clinically would behave
as almost close to her two negative
obviously we still have to treat them as
we're too positive
but keep in the back of our mind that
these probably the treatment treatment
her2 anti-her2 treatment in these
patients is not
as effective and and this is actually
also confirmed by the
literature by some of the published
literature
and so the uh this is it
i am at the end now and i think we did a
good job we got uh
50 minutes or less and so
the focused updates the 2018 focused up
they
really moved closer to incorporating
the protein status with the gene status
almost on all tumors
the guidelines obviously they already
swung the pendulum in the negative
result direction
which i actually welcome to some extent
and then it did not really solve the
dilemma the grazon tumor even though
the oncologists are jubilant about the
disappearance of the equivocal her2
category but that disappearance is
actually artificial so we really
dichotomized
artificially dichotomized a continuous
variable in my opinion
and did not eliminate the problem of
grazon tumor we still have to address
that
so therefore i personally propose that
three-tier scoring
uh her too positive or too negative or
too low
and i think dr shelly gunn my colleague
who does a lot of
uh cgas
comparative genomic hybridization
testing sheets all agree with that
conclusion
and of course correlation with
immunistic chemistry and tumor
histopathology and performing the
metrics is really in my opinion
mandatory in order to improve or to
testing accuracy
this is really the most important
statement and this is the message i
would like for everybody
uh to take home and with that i really
appreciate your attention and i welcome
your questions
at this point at this point thank you
thank you dr yaziji for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the q the live q a
portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
our first question is
what do you do with low-grade tumors
that have a her2-positive status by
either immunohistochemistry
or fish sure
thank you jennifer um basically
i apply the same tools that i get in the
toolbox
basically i always use the same tools i
have in the toolbox i pull them out
low brake tumors generally speaking are
not supposed to be
or too positive but like i said earlier
there are exceptions and the exceptions
follow a specific rule that rule
says at least the rule that i
observed over more than looking at more
than
23 000 tumors is
basically the nuclear score
if the nuclear score is one
then the tumor should really be negative
should not be positive i have not seen a
tumor that is positive
for her2 with a nuclear score of one out
of three
but when the nuclear score becomes
higher than one
either two or three out of three then
all bets are off
and the tumor actually is allowed for
the lack of a better word
is allowed to be or too positive
so it is perfectly fine
for breast cancers to be positive when
they are low grade
with a with the condition that the
nuclear score is higher than one now if
you have a nuclear score of one
and a positive status you you really
should not have that combination
so you should
if you only have a municipality you
should do fish maybe there's something
wrong with the assay with the ihc assay
you should do fish and fish would be
negative and maybe the ihc assay
shows some high sensitivity issues
sometimes the fixation of the tumor
plays a role in bumping the
her2 status i have never seen a a three
plus positive tumor
that is with a artificially three plus
signal by hc
but i have seen tumors with like what
looks like convincingly two plus signal
um and which is really not
representative of two plus but it's more
like should be one plus
and the increase in the intensity is due
to
shorter fixation of the tumor and
formaldehyde so what happens is when
they
get to the tissue processor the next
solution that they are hit
with the tumor is hit with is actually
alcohol
and alcohol brings up the signal her2
signal
you know so her two likes alcohol
and and so you get artificially a more
intense
her2 protein copy by hc but you do fish
and and you get negative results so
that's what i do with these tumors
okay and
our next question is can you please
elaborate more on the her2 driven tumors
sure so that is one of my
favorite areas because that's where we
need to get a little bit more granular
and go beyond the dichotomy of positive
versus negative
okay so having a her2 positive status is
not the end of the story
and that really shows where the medical
oncologist
a very astute medical oncologist would
really look
beyond the positive result
so they put it all together so if the
tumor is
positive for her to protein expression
and or gene amplification
and negative for more hormone receptors
with a
really higher nuclear grade but also
a high t67 for people who do perform
e67 assay
if you put it all together a
tumor that is negative for hormone
receptor expression but positive for
her2
these are the tumors this is the group
of tumors where i personally feel that
the patient gets the most benefit
of anti-her2 therapy and that therapy is
unopposed
by the hormone receptor status on the
tumor
because there is good literature a
couple of studies that show that
patients who have positive hormone
receptor status
for some reason the positive status
tends to block
the beneficial effects of anti-her2
therapy
as opposed to patients with a her2
driven tumor where the
protein the hormone receptor is actually
completely negative
so that's why i like to call these
tumors driven by her2 because her2 seems
to really drive the biology and the
clinical course
in these patients
okay great well those are all the
questions we have
thank you again dr hattie yazoji and
thank you again to the audience
um for those outstanding questions we
hope you found today's presentation to
be informative and insightful
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing
don't miss out on the other valuable
presentations on our agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
and until next time
goodbye